нам цього містечка такий його кухня на
спортивного майданчика в авдіївці
святих за україни обхідну помелу та
поспішає ви склали холодом чи то голодом
без мети між кінці після пережитого тут
половити апатія простіше рубані це на
вірно агресія і ти це кадр
українська навіть служба на 2 чайні
ситуації роздаю мамалигу та сладкий чай
портали ці сироти хто пряма
допомогу профіль наставниця доплати в
києві найкращим закупили цими шипами звідси
допоможу надіслала інвалідам хлопцям ікра
шип закупила зброю україні зброю
україна скелі з моєю ж 35000 мішкан
тефни не разом завищується ще близько
15000 для них цифри 3 за maven і звичайно
всі
відомо всі люди хочуть світу cool
ебашить ризикового шкір, кулай
закінчити октябрина
у сильно бридлав спад і в страху всім
набридло
по страху від того ж вночі особливо
часто обстрілювати один із джутових
пляшки вікі по трапу лапід арт і
танковий обстріл про ланцюг dist повністю
житло ви і тут мишкою люди живуть люди
глава авдеїв sky ризиково цивільний
адміністрації павла малихін перевіряючи
ситуацію особливо його і ось і спокій частка
авдіївський коксохім за воду в одному з
найбільших у Європі як би в нього вивчив
і сталося оп-оп-оп рівні будика логічно
тату строго боягуз на заводі та доступ
аватари чуричів індики є
потроєним і тим часом закривала не ніж
його в директі нагадує про тих, хто
заглянувши то ти хто поттер бойовик
гуманітарні щури
при наймі їх не страждання знову вас прямий
і вали пам'ятають і міжнародні зміни
на війну в Україні